[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara halbwegs guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport
bald zwei wochen dauert dieser krieg ein
ende ist nicht abzusehen im gegenteil
panzer rollen offenbar auf kiew zu in
besonders umkämpften städten verstärkt
russland seine angriffe die ukraine
lehnt flucht korridore nach russland ab
die zahl der flüchtlinge aus dem
kriegsgebiet steigt auf 1,7 millionen
die meisten menschen fliehen nach polen
in europa wächst die furcht vor einer
energiekrise der ölpreis klettert
zeitweise auf den höchsten stand seit
seit zwölf tagen tobt der krieg in der
ukraine die diplomatischen bemühungen um
ein ende der angriffe dauern an die
situation der menschen in den belagerten
städten wird immer katastrophaler auch
weil die russischen truppen
entscheidende infrastruktur die wasser
und stromversorgung zerstört haben der
hafenstadt mario pohl droht eine
humanitäre katastrophe
christoph distel und sarah laska
mario pohl im süden hier ist der krieg
besonders brutal bilder der angriffe
gibt es kaum diese vom ukrainischen
militär sollen vom samstag seien ein
soldat vertröstet menschen die weg
wollen zu gefährlich sei das im moment
verzweifelte frauen fragen nach am
nachmittag vielleicht oder morgen
über 300.000 einwohner warten so heißt
es ohne wasser strom und heizung der
stellvertretende bürgermeister nennt das
völkermorden
fast alle gebäude der stadt sind
zerstört die leute leben nur noch in
kellern ihr größter wunsch ist wasser
nicht einmal essen
zwar stehen die busse für die flucht
bereit doch aus dem geplanten
humanitären korridoren wurde wieder
nichts moskau sagt er weg will darf aber
nur nach belarus oder russland kiew
entgegnet auf keinen fall
diese variante für flucht korridore
können wir nicht akzeptieren unsere
mitbürger werden nicht nach belarus
gehen um dann weit nach russland zu
fliegen
bleiben und sich wehren das gilt sogar
noch in der ersten vom russischen
militär eingenommenen großstadt
eigentlich dürfen die bewohner von
personen nicht mehr vor die tür aber
draußen rufen sie den russischen
besatzern entgegen geht nach hause die
vorher in die luft ein pulverfass
insgesamt ist die militärische lage etwa
so im süden an den strategisch wichtigen
meeres zugängen ist das russische
militär am weitesten gekommen archiv im
nordosten soll schwer umkämpft aber
nicht eingekesselt sein und der
hauptstadt kiew nähern sich von nord und
ost offenbar weitere truppeneinheiten
vor allem mit panzern sollen diese
bilder des russischen militärs zeigen
die größte zerstörung kommt aber weiter
aus der luft bilder zeigt war und ihn
schwer getroffen der ukrainische
präsident beschwört den westen
wie viele menschen müssen noch sterben
bis der himmel über der ukraine
gesichert wird inwiefern sind friedliche
menschen in hartz iv oder nikolaev
anders als in hamburg oder wien
kiew zumindest wappnet sich für den
großen angriff freiwillige ziehen
barrikaden hoch auch annabel eigentlich
tanzlehrerin jetzt fest entschlossen
erstens tue ich das für unser land
zweitens haben wir keine verwandten wo
wir hingehen könnten und drittens
glauben wir an unsere truppen
mit allen mitteln versucht die stadt
kiew die kampfmoral der einwohner zu
stärken auch mit propaganda etwa eine
hochzeit im tarnanzug kämpferin gibt
kämpfer das jawort und bürgermeister
klitschko gehört zu den ersten
gratulanten
am nachmittag begann die dritte
verhandlungsrunde zwischen den
kriegsparteien in belarus katrin
eigendorf was es da zu erwarten
ja michael ballack der berater des
präsidenten und eines der mitglieder der
verhandlungsdelegation hatte kurz bevor
die verhandlungen gestartet sind einen
ziemlich bitteren tweets auf twitter
abgesetzt und gesagt wir ziehen jetzt in
verhandlungen mit menschen die brutal
und absichtlich zivilisten beschießen
die wir jetzt aus der
verhandlungsdelegation hören hat man
heute einen winzigen erfolg erzielt das
ist die nachricht zur stunde dass man
sich wohl darauf geeinigt hat zwischen
beiden parteien dass es einen
waffenstillstand erneut gibt den versuch
ihn durch zu halten um so genannte
flucht korridore zu schaffen wie
belastend wie haltbar das ist das wird
sich natürlich erst zeigen müssen und
die ganz großen pessimisten hier im
lande sagen das macht russland um
zivilbevölkerung aus den umkämpften
städten rauszuholen zum beispiel
beispiel aus mario pohl um dann
besonders hart zuzuschlagen und in
diesem krieg noch einmal ganz deutlich
zu eskalieren die große hoffnung von
selen ski und ich würde auch sagen von
der masse der ukrainischen bevölkerung
ist wirklich der westen und immer wieder
steht die forderung nach schließung des
luftraums hier als großes thema zur
debatte als große forderung dankeschön
katrin eigendorf aus chemnitz geht
auch der regierungen des westens suchen
weiter nach wegen den krieg zu beenden
heute kamen bundeskanzler scholz us
präsident biden frankreichs staatschefs
makro und der britische premier johnson
in einer video konferenz zusammen nach
den gemeinsamen beratungen sagte kanzler
scholz sie hoffen dass die sanktionen
eindruck machen und ein feld für
diplomatische gespräche eröffnen dabei
wird weiter diskutiert mit welchen
waffen deutschland die ukraine noch
unterstützen kann zunächst lieferte die
bundeswehr 5000 helme später aufgestellt
aufgestockt auf 23.000 dazu kamen dann
500 luftabwehrraketen vom typ sting
sowie 1000 panzerabwehrwaffen auch 2700
strehler boden strategen aus alten ddr
beständen gehen in der ukraine über
weitere militärhilfen berät nun der
verteidigungsausschuss klaus brodbeck
was geht noch was von dem was die
bundeswehr materialien bären kann könnte
die us armee auch tatsächlich einsetzen
und haben die bisher versprochenen
hilfen die ukraine schon erreicht wir
haben schon geliefert und damit ich auch
um verständnis dass lieferwege auch
nicht veröffentlicht werden auch zur
sicherheit dass die waffen die
angekündigt sind dann auch ankommt und
wir sind dabei weiterhin zu prüfen aber
es muss auch immer klar sein dass wir
unsere bundeswehr dabei nicht schwächen
dürfen details dazu sollen erst gegen
ende der geheimsitzung mitgeteilt werden
noch offen daher ob deutschlands
unterstützungs versuche hilfreich sind
oder hilflos
bisherigen lieferung der lenk flug
raketen und auch der panzerabwehrwaffen
haben sehr geholfen und haben auch dazu
beigetragen dass der russische aufmarsch
in kiew herum zum erliegen gekommen ist
das würde natürlich die aktion helme für
die ukraine noch um ein schlimmeres
übertreffen wenn jetzt munition und alt
waffen aus beständen der bundeswehr an
die ukraine geliefert werden würden die
nicht einsatzfähig sind sogar vielleicht
sogar noch für das personal dass es
einsetzt eine sicherheitsgefährdung
darstellen waffenlieferungen und 100
milliarden zur modernisierung der
bundeswehr teile der grünen haben daran
noch immer zu kommen
mein gefühl und meine rückmeldung die
ich bekomme ist dass es ein sehr breit
getragen ist das ein neuer kurs von der
bundesrepublik jetzt ausgeht und sehr
viel verständnis dafür gibt das heißt
aber nicht dass wir nicht mehr genau hin
coco was passiert zwei stunden schon
sitzen sie und beraten es könnte noch
länger gehen es gibt so viele fragen
manche haben die hoffnung des russlands
bürgerinnen und bürger stärker gegen
diesen krieg aufbegehren
doch wer das tut muss mit drastischen
konsequenzen rechnen wie tausende
demonstrierende am wochenende und das am
freitag verschärfte mediengesetz macht
unabhängige berichterstattung in
russland unmöglich goliath teil
berichtet
die ukrainische hymne erklingt in moskau
in der nähe des roten platzes für einen
nur kurzen moment es war der letzte
sonntag vor dem großen fasten der
sonntag der vergebung als tausende
russen auf die straßen gingen und über
5.000 festgenommen wurden jede spur des
protests ausgelöst ein polizist
entfernte den satz kein krieg der in den
schnee geschrieben wurde selbst auf dem
eis der flüsse wurde das nein zum krieg
prompt über markt
schläge und tritte sogar gegen
demonstrierende frauen die noch im land
verbliebenen liberalen oppositionellen
erleben derzeit durchsuchungen sie
sprechen von militärzensur
millionen menschen sind im bild eher
angst in einem solchen zustand war unser
land noch nie in der nachkriegszeit die
menschen schauen buchstäblich hinter
ihren rücken und zu sehen ob da gefahr
oder überwachung ist es wird sehr schwer
für uns diese zeit bestehen das ist eine
kolossale prüfung
im sibirischen tomsk verabschiedet sich
ein chefredakteur von seinem team die
unabhängige regionale fernsehsender tv2
beendet seine arbeit eine weitere sorge
trägt die journalisten um nach
unbestätigten berichten könnte sich
russland schon bald vom weltweiten
internet abzocke
im großen und ganzen wäre das technisch
möglich man schreckt bis jetzt noch
davor zurück legen der wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen aber für die user in
russland brechen harte zeiten
russlands
kommunikationsministerium verneinte
solche ab trennungspläne heute nach den
gestrigen protesten zogen autokorsos
durch verschiedene städte um symbolisch
russlands armee zu unterstützen
schon 1,7 millionen menschen sind nach
angaben des un hcr innerhalb der
vergangenen zwölf tage aus der ukraine
geflohen die meisten davon 60 prozent
ins nachbarland polen dort empfängt sie
riesige solidarität und
hilfsbereitschaft die geflüchteten
sollen schnell wohnungen und jobs
bekommen damit könnten sie auch polen
helfen in der hebei streit hat mir mit
dem grenzübertritt nach polen beginnt
für die meisten geflüchteten aus der
ukraine ein neues leben sie werden so
sieht es jetzt aus nicht so bald nach
hause zurückkehren können polens
arbeitsmarkt kann sie aber brauchen
schon jetzt erwirtschaften ukraine hier
13 prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes zb
im transportgewerbe
vorgänger seit vielen jahren und das
arbeit die zusammenarbeit entwickelt
sich sehr gut bis heute dieser situation
dass wir sagen für seine lastwagen
thelen ihm jetzt viele fahrer im ganzen
land werden mitarbeiter gesucht
branchenübergreifend gibt es in polen
600.000 offene stellen die
arbeitsverwaltung ist zuversichtlich
viele geflüchtete unterzubringen
touristisch ist es selbstverständlich
dass erwachsene die die grenze
überschreiten sie früher oder später an
ihren schweren job finden das ist kein
problem zum beispiel in der gastronomie
wo arbeitgebern polnische oder englische
sprachkenntnisse als qualifikation schon
reichen im gastgewerbe suchen wir
ständig unterschiedlichste arbeitskräfte
wie zimmermädchen putzpersonal küchen
und servicekette es werden sicher jobs
finden ich denke ja
die lage in der ukraine hat den polen
großes mitleid mit den geflüchteten
ausgelöst die sich hier ein neues leben
aufbauen müssen deswegen hat das
familienministerium schnell solche
flugblätter gedruckt mit informationen
wo man sich bewerben kann und was die
voraussetzungen sind um in polen einen
job zu kriegen die chancen für einen
neuanfang sind als da auch wenn es für
die betroffenen sehr schwer wird das
nachbarland als neue heimat anzunehmen
in deutschland sind mittlerweile
mindestens 50.000 menschen aus der
ukraine angekommen auch mehr als 100
mädchen und jungen aus einem jüdischen
waisenhaus in odessa einige sind
vollwaisen andere wurden von ihren
eltern mitgeschickt seit freitag sind
sie in berlin heute bekommen sie besuch
von bundespräsidentin henriette de
maizière und markus gross berichten
dpa david wie heißt du
abraham levy jüdische kinder aus odessa
gerettet aus den wirren des krieges
gerade einmal 36 tage alt ist das
jüngste baby abgegeben von seiner mutter
damit es in sicherheit gebracht wird
105 kinder waren mehr als 50 stunden
unterwegs bis sie am vergangenen freitag
im jüdischen zentrum habath angekommen
sind
ganz besondere aufgabe ganz besondere
ehre hier zu spielen und es gibt keinen
besseren weg die dunklen vergangenheit
wieder gutzumachen aus und positiven
oder bündig in fröhlichen zukunft in
deutschland zu suchen
heute zu gast bei krabat berlin
bundespräsident steinmeier er zeigte
sich dankbar für die große solidarität
der bevölkerung
wir deutsche möchten den geflüchteten
die opfer des menschenverachtenden
krieges in der ukraine sind
wir möchten ihnen zur seite stehen
hier bekommen die kinder und
jugendlichen ruhe und ein sicheres dach
über dem kopf
wir sind auch so deshalb weil krieg ist
richtig krieg und das ist schwer zu
verstehen jedes mal wenn ich auf mein
handy schauen
in der ukraine ist es eine schreckliche
situation und ich bin froh dass wir
unsere leben retten konnten
immer mehr menschen fliehen aus der
ukraine
13.000 kam allein gestern in berlin an
sie suchen zuflucht und schutz
überwältigend ist die
spendenbereitschaft in deutschland
allein für das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe kamen bislang rund 67
millionen euro zusammen wenn auch sie
helfen wollen die iban des
aktionsbündnisses lautet de 65 104 106
100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf nothilfe
ukraine alle infos auch unter spenden
punkt zdf.de oder im zdf text auf seite
8 190
auch die wirtschaftlichen folgen dieses
krieges zeigen sich immer deutlicher vor
allem bei den energiepreisen der
gaspreis explodierte heute regelrecht
+60 prozent kaum besser die lage beim öl
1 barrel also 159 liter der nordseesorte
brent war in den letzten jahren meist
für deutlich unter 100 us dollar zu
haben seit dem russischen angriff geht
es massiv nach oben aus angst vor dem
ausfall russischer quellen martin neeson
hat mir
diese jenseits der zwei euro marke
benzin und super ebenso der krieg in der
ukraine treibt die preise an den
zapfsäulen auf immer neue höhen das
kennen wir ja auch von vergangenen
ölkrisen oder wenn kriege stattgefunden
haben dass insbesondere der ölpreis
durch die decke ging jetzt haben wir als
einen beteiligten auch noch russland das
heißt es war abzusehen dass hier sehr
stark die preise nach oben gehen werden
elf prozent des weltweit geförderten öls
stammen aus russland platz drei hinter
den usa und saudi arabien in deutschland
allerdings liegt russisches öl mit 34
prozent und weitem abstand auf platz
eins danach kommen die usa mit 12,5
kasachstan norwegen und großbritannien
mit knapp zehn prozent was also wenn
deutschland und die eu nun russisches öl
boykottieren also erstmal besteht kein
grund zur panik weil wir haben eine
bevorratung für 90 tage das heißt wir
haben rohöl aber auch rohprodukte heizöl
kraftstoffe und ähnliches für 90 tage
eingelagert und können drei monate
überbrücken und zweitens ist der
rohölmarkt sehr vielschichtig wir können
also relativ schnell auf andere staaten
und andere lieferländer umsteigen zum
beispiel aus der opec die opec könnte
einfach die fördermenge erhöhen eine
echte ölknappheit gibt es nämlich nicht
wohl aber nervöse märkte und selbst
erwählten abhängigkeit aus ihr heraus zu
kommen dauert deutschland ist bei
importen eigentlich schon sehr gut
diversifiziert wir beziehen aus 30
ländern weltweit und gerade jetzt haben
die mineralölgesellschaften sich
entschlossen
die aktuelle rekord rallye an den
zapfsäulen wird das aber so schnell
nicht stoppen
wollen wir mrt wissen in washington was
tun die usa um die ölpreise und die
abhängigkeit von russland zu senken
ja die us-regierung hat vorhin noch
einmal drei millionen barrel öl aus der
strategischen reserve freigegeben und
sie redet jetzt ich sage mal salopp mit
spitzen fingern mit jedem der vielleicht
abhilfe schaffen könnte amerikanische
unterhändler sind derzeit in venezuela
man bietet an das öl embargo aufzuheben
wenn es villa ist ja verbandelt mit
russland auch da aber das geld in sofern
die hoffnung wenn man sich einigt auch
einen keil zwischen russland und
venezuela zu treiben zum zweiten hofft
man auf einen baldigen abschluss des
atomdeals mit dem iran dann könnte man
die sanktionen aufheben aber die frage
ist wieviel zugeständnisse müsste man
dafür machen und hier im weißen haus
hinter uns berät man darüber presse denn
beiden persönlich nach saudi arabien
reißt die beziehungen zwischen beiden
ländern sind ja sehr angeschlagen seit
der ermordung des journalisten karl
jaggy aber wenn man es schafft mit mehr
öl in den weltmärkten russlands
energielieferungen zu ersetzen und
putins ölhahn zuzudrehen dann so hören
wir hier ist das wichtiger als die moral
im umgang mit solchen autoritären regime
dankeschön für diese informationen aus
washington im aktiven war dass der
ukrainische präsident see lenski rief
heute erneut eindringlich dazu auf die
sanktionen gegen russland weiter zu
verschärfen und auch russisches öl zu
boykottieren über die diskussion darüber
in deutschland berichtet britta buchholz
noch zahlen wie russland für gas kohle
und erdöl mehrere hundert millionen euro
täglich während des krieges einige
drängen deutlich auf einem boykott trotz
der auswirkungen
es wird folgen haben da darf man sich
nichts vormachen
wir müssen aber auch eben sehen was
dagegen steht das ist alles was wir tun
können diesen krieg in dem gestorben
wird in dem vernichtet wird zu beenden
und nicht uns zu beteiligen an einem
finanzierungsgeschäft für diesen krieg
der bundeskanzler macht heute per
pressemitteilung klar er ist gegen eine
sanktion auf energie die versorgung kann
im moment nicht anders gesichert werden
denn weder im bereich kohle noch bei öl
oder gas gibt es ausreichend
alternativen und die preise steigen so
sehr dass der finanzminister der
industrie helfen will
hier kann ich
sie und auch die wirtschaft versichern
dass wir das was möglich ist tun um
schaden von unserer wirtschaft
abzuwenden existenz gewährt gefährdung
abzuwenden und den verlust von
beschäftigung zu verhindern viele
fürchten bei einer sanktion bei energie
dramatisch steigende preise die csu will
die mehrwertsteuer auf benzin senken wir
sind ja jetzt schon an die situation
dass die preise nach oben explodieren
das geht ein paar tage aber nicht
dauerhaft für viele menschen ist es eine
massive beeinträchtigung wir brauchen
auch gerade beim thema benzin und an der
zapfsäule eine absolute energiepreis
bremse so schnell wie möglich die
politik muss entscheiden ob sie einen
importstopp für öl gas oder kohle
riskieren will es sind schwierige
abwägungen in schwierigen tagen
sie sind einer von uns und wir wollen
sie drinnen haben so sagte es
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen vor
ein paar tagen richtung ukraine
jetzt prüft brüssel den beitrittsantrag
der ukraine den das land offiziell nach
dem russischen einmarsch gestellt hatte
auch die anträge georgiens und
moldawiens sollen bewertet werden
russland muss gestoppt werden das
fordert die ukraine vor dem
internationalen gerichtshof in den haag
kiew hatte das oberste us gericht
angerufen und beschuldigt russland
kriegsverbrechen zu begehen die ukraine
verlangt dass moskau die kampfhandlungen
sofort einstellt russland sollte morgen
gehört werden boykottiert aber den
prozess
weitere ausführliche informationen über
den russland ukraine krieg und seine
folgen in unserer zdf heute app und
gleich in einem zdf spezial nach dieser
heute sendung
schauen wir auf die korona zahlen die
steigen weiter das robert koch institut
meldet 78 1428 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden über 16.000 mehr als vor einer
woche
24 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages dazu die sieben tage incidents
liegt nun knapp über
1200 19 80 also steigende corona zahlen
aber die impfkampagne sie stagniert nach
wie vor groß waren die erwartungen als
vor einer woche der alternative
impfstoff nowaks auf den nova wachse auf
den markt kam er sollte im skeptiker
überzeugen doch nowaks scheint ein
ladenhüter zu sein berichtet daniela
sonntag aus thüringen
genug nowaks haben sie hier in der
impfstelle im katholischen krankenhaus
in erfurt was aber fehlt sind die
impfwilligen nur wenige holen sich jetzt
die spritze mit dem alternativen
impfstoff mir war es lieber mich mit
einem herkömmlichen impfstoff impfen zu
lassen bei den anderen also diesen mit
dem m rna da war ich mir nicht so sicher
draußen gesundheitswesen kommen
und ich mich impfen lassen weil ich
sonst in meine arbeit verlieren würde
bin ich quasi gezwungen nicht irgendwie
zu lassen dabei sollte nur wachse die
hoffnung auch m rna skeptiker überzeugen
und so die impfkampagne wieder in
schwung bringen rund 2,4 millionen dosen
des stoffes stehen derzeit bundesweit
zur verfügung doch verimpft sind davon
bisher nur rund
22.000 viel zu wenig man kann sagen dass
die erwartungen bisher enttäuscht wurden
wir haben mit viel mehr nachfrage
gerechnet insbesondere natürlich auch
bei dem personal was der impfpflicht
unterliegen wird bei dem personal der
kritischen infrastruktur und allen
anderen die sich bisher noch nicht haben
impfen lassen grund vielleicht auch weil
nowaks bisher nur für die erste und
zweite impfung zugelassen ist ich bin
leider ein bisschen irritiert darüber
dass man mit nowaks im moment noch keine
booster impfung machen lassen kann
weil das noch nicht zugelassen ist da
bin ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
skeptisch neuer impfstoff neue fragen
trotz nowaks stockt die impfkampagne
weiterhin
alle jahre wieder dieselbe erkenntnis am
equal pay day frauen verdienen in
deutschland immer noch deutlich weniger
als männer das belegen zahlen des
statistischen bundesamts demnach
bekommen frauen im schnitt 18 prozent
weniger gehalt als männer ein grund
frauen arbeiten häufiger in schlechter
bezahlten berufen oder in teilzeit auch
gibt es immer noch mehr männer als
frauen in führungspositionen und
jetzt zu dir norbert und zum erste
deutsche gold bei den parallel der mono
skifahrerin anna lena foster hat es
endlich geschafft nachdem wir gestern
einen sieg haarscharf verpasst hatte
heute in der super-kombination zunächst
eine völlig verkorkste erste disziplin
dann aber eine furiose aufholjagd
die achterbahnfahrt von anna-lena
forster beginnt unter tränen ich denke
ich bin ihn einfach zu wenige auf zug
gefahren hier verunglückter super g 6
sekunden rückstand als vierte in der
super-kombination nun der slalom 7
paralympischen medaillen hat sich schon
gewonnen und vorerst auf platz eins alle
weiteren vorliegenden sind schlechter
sogar die japanerin yuka bis dato 2
fache paralympische siegerin in china
ich kann noch gar nicht so richtig
begreifen weil ich niemals gedacht hätte
dass ich sechs sekunden aufholen kann
der farbe lauf von forster bringt das
erste gold für deutschland
gestern holten sie im biathlon silber
und bronze heute das gleiche nochmal im
15 kilometer langlauf die beiden
deutschen nachwuchsfahrer athletinnen
also wieder erfolgreich lin katzmaier 15
jahre jung und die 18 jährige leonie
walter
in der hellen mittagssonne machten sich
den katzmaier und ihr geld florian
baumann auf den weg gut 52 minuten
später erreichten die beiden mit der
zweitbesten laufzeit das ziel
sehr hart aber es hat auch mega spaß
gemacht wie am vortag konnte sich katz
meyers wg mitbewohnerin leonie walter
mit sky match tracker über die
bronzemedaille freuen siegerin wurde wie
schon beim gestrigen biathlon die
ukrainerin oxana schäfer morgen werden
sich die drei paare im biathlon über 10
kilometer wohl wieder um die medaillen
streiten
fußball bundesliga das sonntagabend
spiel gestern der knappe sieg von
hoffenheim in köln das einzige und damit
entscheidende tollen der 61 minute nach
schöner flanke von david raum auf tsg
innenverteidiger stephan pusch
hoffenheim jetzt tabellen vierter und
damit auf einem champions league platz
köln bleibt achter
alle begegnungen alle tore des 25
spieltags zu sehen bei zdf heute.de und
in der cdu foto app dankeschön bitte
nach eisigen nächten gibt es diese woche
viel sonne und es wird tagsüber langsam
bilder die details hat gleich katja
hornuf danach das zdf spezial viertel
vor zehn begrüßt sie dann christian
sievers im heute-journal
dankeschön für ihr interesse wir
wünschen ihnen alles gute bis morgen
hätten auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute hat das etwas
geschneit hier im bayerischen wald und
zwischen weser und elbe hielt sich am
vormittag noch etwas nebel aber am
frühen nachmittag war es mit dem nebel
dann vorbei und es gab nur harmlose
wolkenfelder und so wird es heute nacht
klar und deswegen auch kalt die
temperaturen sinken auf werte zwischen -
1 grad auf den ostfriesischen inseln und
minus 10 grad am alpenrand
allenfalls ganz im osten zum beispiel
hier in ostsachsen in berlin und
brandenburg vielleicht aber auch in
schleswig-holstein bildet sich mal etwas
nebel sonst gibt es allenfalls ein paar
hochnebelfelder aber der wind legt
morgen zu es ist ein wind aus östlichen
bis südöstlichen richtungen und das
bedeutet nebel und hochnebel haben nicht
viel chancen und lösen sich meist schon
am frühen vormittag auf dann gibt es
strahlenden sonnenschein und das bei
temperaturen zwischen vier grad am
alpenrand und 12 grad am niederrhein das
wird jetzt aber von tag zu tag wärmer am
freitag erwartet uns dann höchst
temperaturen von sieben grad auf rügen
und 17 grad am niederrhein am wetter
ändert sich derweil wenig nach etwas
nebel am morgen gibt es jede menge
sonnenschein und erst am freitag werden
die wolken von westen ein kleines
bisschen dichter guten abend